it's a game today if I remember  correctly I don't think she played  rounds one and two I don't know yeah  yeah exactly yeah she was playing she's  playing her first game of the Olympia  today  and we are getting the message from  satis that harika is eight months  pregnant  this is uh okay then then it's also kind  of understandable that they understand  that she is such an incredibly strong  player that the team needs her but  probably you should not over push her  yeah he has to be has to be carefully  the workload has to be carefully  carefully managed but of course the team  is stronger with her in it so  um yeah such a such a great player I  mean she's 2500 for I don't know 10  years or something it's um  I think she was either close or above  2600 at one point I'm pretty sure  um yeah but yet another Carlsbad where